ونظرا لان تويتر يتكون من مليارات
التفاعلات يوميا يمكن اعتباره بمثابه ذكاء
الكترونيا جماعيا فائق مع ادخل تعديلات
بسيطه
تغريده كتبها ماسك بعد الاستحواذ اعرف قطع
صورته صغيرا لكن هل عليه ان يقلق من هذا
الذكاء الفائق الى ماسك في جحيم تويتر
عنوانه مقالنا انشره موقع دافيرج المتخصص
بشؤون التكنولوجيا والسؤال لماذا جحيم ان
كان يريد ماسك زياده اعداد المستخدمين
للموقع وبالتالي زياده عائلته لا يملك الا
ان يقدم تنازلات وبعض هذه التنازلات لها
غريبه فالمشكلات التي يواجهها تويتر ليست
هندسيه وانما سياسيه وياتي على راس
اولويات المنصه الاهتمام بالمستخدمين مما
جعلهم بمثابه الاصول المهمه لموقع تويتر
وهو ما يعقد الامر اكثر
لذا يجب الحفاظ على استقطابهم واستمرارهم
في نشر التغريدات مماسك واحد منهم اي انه
دفع 44 مليار دولار لشراء نفسه الحقيقه ان
ماسك بين ميزان حريه التعبير والقانون لذا
عليه وفقه الكاتبه حضر بعض العبارات بحسب
القانون اذا كان يريد كسب المال وفي هذه
الحاله سيكون عرضه للانتقاد من الاجيال
الشابه اليمنيه لكن ماذا عن خارج الحدود
الامريكيه على سبيل المثال لنقول
الالمانيه تعد سوقا كبيرا لسيارات شركه
تسلا التي يمتلكها ماسك والامر نفسه موجود
في الهند وكذلك في العديد من الدول الاخرى
ومنها امريكا بالطبع بشان المحتوى الذي
يتم نشره عبر شبكات التواصل بهذه
المناسبات
يحاولون تد حريه التعبير
[موسيقى]